it's loading okay I'm up Bob's in the Ghana whichever will it be I'll make you
cover a new PewDiePie song don't think I won't I like that PewDiePie
no it's so good though oh crap I can hear myself oops I didn't close the
mainstream okay there we go I hear no yeah let me just make sure my life or
I'm on live chat mommy's here yeah mommy's got a friend Azura Delay that
is Azura she she's got blue hair which is not green these accusations that Azura
has blue hair are unfounded and I will not take such slander I've got green
okay Azura life okay right now to give you guys the you think you think
hold on a minute I'm about to open up Azura stream give me a second just to
make sure she's up we had a few technical difficulties as any stream ever
goes no you're not I'm not what are you streaming to
right now because you're not live did you select stream maybe maybe maybe it's
taking time maybe it's taking time it's taking time oh you may have latency on
by accident hmm I'm on Azura stream but it doesn't say she's there but she's
live streaming though it says it's set for an hour yes every support I asked
Azura very kindly if she could give me one hour earlier and she said yes and
then we both realized 15 minutes before we were gonna go live that we don't
actually have the game downloaded so thank you for the game being tiny and we
could both download it in time and why is your stream not up oh my god sorry look
it's not a collab if there's nayscuff let's be honest there's not a collab if
there's nayscuff so stream about to stop well we're body opens oh my god leaving a
like on your stream thank you thank you what who or what are you sure you've
hit go live it says end broadcast and stop streaming bottom right doesn't say
go live yeah and you selected the we were here collab that's right God if
you're streaming at some random location the broadcast failed the broadcast
failed okay that makes more sense would you like to reattempt the broadcast by
selecting we were here and try again but there's a please try again and again
and 10 to 30 seconds that's so specific this Ronnie's here to add to witness my
curse I told you guys I told you right so we've been like chat away for like an
hour and stuff and we're just talking about her no she's just sent me a
screenshot says transition in the broad the broadcast is failed give it 30
seconds if this error persists open the broadcast in YouTube studio and try
manually which one of you will play ADC and who will support if you don't get it
ask is there she can help you whoa which is that you mean oh for goodness sake oh
for goodness sake but I'm looking at our donors on rewards and it's like oh let's
do smash or pass leak I'm like I see a leak one more time but as long as you
smash on jinx and I'll allow it because jinx is my most man I'm really going to
hello okay do you want to try reselect in the store I'm going to turn off this so
that it closes it and then I'm a restart it yes so that I can manually restart it
yeah come on let's just enjoy the ambience reeflings of this I have a
bit of an update about ASMR scripts you're not ready for it I wrote a script
for AC I'm about to write a script for Azura and then I'm about to write one
for Mercy and everyone's getting forced to do ASMR I'm Ben I'm literally
twisting their arms behind their back I'm like you better record this ASMR I'm
gonna fart on your eyelashes I didn't say that part out load to Azura but
internally she knows the threat is there not my eyelashes
okay now I can just press I'll just I'll just do it manually
I hear there it is I'm so ready
are you live for real for real yeah yeah yeah yeah oh so really all so OBS was
just having a hissy fit then hold on yeah I've got me honey tea reeflings and
bleeding hearts
I can't believe it isn't the real Azura Dulay the fertility goddess of real or I can't believe it
that's a goddess of fertility but if you want to be fertility goddess I'll
it all of the above you're up oh thank god whoa you're freaking honkers are
massive on your screen oh my god they just about poked my yeah damn which had
some 3d glasses on the hook okay right you're up I'm happy that's all that
okay are you ready to go for it now I will preface this by saying I strongy
cuttles have played this game once before and she is really has not played
this game before and has no idea what to expect she literally asked me before we
started stream is this a horror game I'm like no I wouldn't make you play a
horror game I wouldn't do that right a slip of tea okay I'm gonna would you like
to be the explorer or the librarian you don't know I don't know yeah I knew it
I knew that sounds like she has no idea what to pick right I'm gonna make you the
explorer to get you nice and brave okay so don't be scared don't be scared
ready now we're gonna mute we're gonna mute in discord oh you need to like you
just need a little tick box next to play from start can you next explorer can
you tick that box on end game yeah if you'd like to tick the box it means you're
gonna ready up I can't oh no I click ready yeah yeah but I'm right ready yeah
wait we're gonna meet in discord because we have to use in game talking so I'm
gonna meet in discord it was lovely talking to you as they're seeing game
don't be scared I promise you're fine she's so nervous she has no idea it's
funny cuz I can still see what she's doing over there like cuz we're streaming
each other's model I can see her talking but I have no idea what she's up to
with shenanigans jump scare I can jump scare in this game unless you can't like
I don't know maybe the walkie-talkie and before she doesn't pick up the walkie
talkie maybe I should have told her to do that
look Azura we should go and follow the footsteps into this forbidden castle for
real for real it's a player it's her a bubba scum jump scare she has her her
badonk I don't sir badonkin sometimes I think Maynard big and then I'm just like
oh yeah I remember when I developed is there remember the time we developed
I had to work through the stream earlier so I'm glad the collab is today oh god
you could catch it thank you for hanging again okay son's going on there's
noises there have we dead well we're dead already we were here yours are nice
jokes is yours the whole damn milk truck it's already over we finna game
finished okay end of collab that was great thanks for having us okay now I'm
not gonna tell Fibbers I have played this game before I don't think I've played
this side of it can I pick you up wait I can't pick it up E oh press V to talk
Azura do you copy over you should pick up the walkie-talkie this you don't pick
it up alright Azura do not be nervous this isn't my first time but I'm happy
to pop your cherry over okay Azura I'm gonna need the specifics I need you to
focus up tell me what you see I repeat tell me what you see over the lies answer
the lie answer the lies okay I repeat copy I don't know what to do with that
over I'm gonna turn her up a little bit can you guys you want me to turn down in
game ambience okay do you have any colored symbols I repeat I colored
pupil symbols over I'm watching her character on my OBS to see if she's
figured something out it's actually really satisfying I love those oh is
this a radio if you hold V over you'll find a radio is she talking to me in
this work no she's not she's made
having it no she has to be using the frickin radio between the eyes Azura I
have a code phrase between the eyes over between the eyes what's that I think
it's a hint for what you're to do something between the eyes over she's
so cute I love her so much I was like all we're gonna breeze through this game
don't worry I played it before I don't want to tell her what to do though I
found symbols on a wall okay perfect tell me what these symbols are over I
think this is the first one if I'm not mistaken yeah there's three there's
three rows and at the top three it's the first time was like a circle with with
a with the X across it and then one going in the middle okay Roger over
huh so I have identified the symbol but I need a symbol along with that either an
eye color pupil or a second shape over I love try hard in the video games what
eye color pupils eye color pupil I have a green eye potentially a blue eye or a
red eye over I have a red eye and a green eye red eye and a green eye do you
need us can you touch symbols in a wall over I think I remember this one I'm
cheating so much and you have a red left eye and a right green eye over I've
just caught up her comes can you repeat that over is this where we find out
can you repeat your last communication over a left red eye and a right green eye
over okay symbols are someone having diarrhea and then the next symbol to
touch is a circle with a cross and a line straight down over
oh come on tell me that's not a bot with someone having diarrhea straight over she's
talking but she's talking for red left and right green the first symbol is diarrhea a
little but with diarrhea straight up line going down it and then the second
symbol is an X a circle and a line going down over I thought it was a fancy tea like
an oh maybe maybe an upside down umbrella might help her a bit better none of
these look like diarrhea though other than that one
little diarrhea can't it couldn't be me I'm constipated again I don't think you
can click them all at once though only one at a time if so the diarrhea symbol or the
upside down umbrella like it got blown in the wind is your first symbol I click that and then
for your second symbol is a circle with a line down and an X through it over
I got I got an achievement I think you did it over
I did it you did it I got an achievement let's go oh new area unlocked for me over
also an area for me there's more symbols no dear I have entered a room with
mutated animals and symbols that are related to them over
I'm sorry mutate mutated yes these animals are not normal they have different body parts
of other animals over I'm scared there's there's strange whispering happening happening in the
in the room I don't want to tell her there's an enemy in the room with her if you could just
find what symbols you need potentially maybe describe paintings in the room to me over
she does not know there's an enemy in the room burb with a skull are you going to be a bit more
specific with the skeleton on its head over does it have chimpanzee feet over
no it has regular burb feet does it have a snail on its back over
with what with what on its back over a snail shell on its back over
nope just a burb with the skeleton head and it looks like it has like two pointy toes on each foot
over yes it does and a white body over yes the white body over and a skull is the last piece
over yes she's actually saying over okay I have three symbols for you are you ready
I'm so ready okay first symbol is ac with a migraine over
okay what do I do with these symbols uh I'm not sure I've got three symbols to give you over
I don't want to tell us over did you do the first one the migraine one
I have it in my hands over okay put it in somewhere that allows you to put three together over
I found it over okay your next symbol is a man in a jacuzzi and he's like a mermaid I guess over
he has a cross here for his head over I love the oh my god I love that she's doing the over
with me I love is there so much she's such a good sport what would you call that then
riflin that's a man in a jacuzzi okay are you ready for your third symbol over
I'm ready for my third symbol over and it is a turtle standee a vtuber turtle standee over
I don't want to tell her there's a monster in her room I got it please work it's wrong
it's wrong we've we've got a problem I think that's right
oh no it was wrong I heard that she has no idea there's a monster in her room
I don't want to freak her out but I think that's the bird um is your just to confirm the bird over
again um we have a skull a white body and long pheasant like legs if you know what a pheasant is over
what's a pheasant oh right it's got like tiny little kneecaps do you see the tiny little kneecaps
over oh yeah I see the kneecaps yes over okay we're gonna go over the three symbols in a row
first one is someone holding their head like they've got a migraine second one is a man in a
jacuzzi with a crosshair head and a mermaid tail and the third one is a turtle on a standee
there's a line below the turtle over that monster is about to get her she's about to freaking scream
she has no idea there's a monster in her room right now
she has no idea I don't want to tell her it's there it's gonna freak her out
oh you did it you did it perfect perfect achievement unlocked over she did it oh my
god she did it wait where the heck's the door this is the door whoa why am I getting so turned
around okay she has no idea she almost just got killed by a monster right what do I need to next
I'm scared over what do you need me what what are you looking at oh god this is a
fucking map no oh my god I'm getting so turned around the fucking
uh this this is the staircase hang on are you I found the door here and pipes oh
are you drowning over hey it's this on the door it says green on the door it says green and water
is rising oh my god I think this this is a layer map you have green shit oh green on the door
and there's pipes everywhere do you have do you need symbol inputs
I don't think so I think she's drowning fuck the table shit I can't remember
is it this I can't remember she's literally drowning fuck I can't remember this is a chest
piece one this is the lantern one and then this is the fucking maze that goes all the way down
I'm missing it this is a massive maze no I don't need to do this one yet um
I don't want to alert you but I'm pretty yeah I don't know what to pull I can't remember
I've got an orange pipe do you have to do it on your end over
I don't know how to stop it I'm sorry I'm looking I don't see anything
what do you mean is there any input you can do on your end or is it all me
no it's all you it's all you how can it be all me
how how how how this is the freaking later map but
oh for fuck's sake and I have no idea I can't remember I can't remember where it is I'm so sorry
right where is I'm I've not played this perspective what the fuck where is it
fucking refland stream snipe right now where is it
I don't know I genuinely don't know how I'm supposed to help her she's drowning right now
oh fuck it we'll just go down here I don't think it's time
I can't find it is there I don't know what to do oh I know what to do what color green green green
oh my god I just I almost killed you I'm so sorry
I just wanted to see you sweat it was all planned sorry it was for clips I'm sorry over
I
didn't I thought that was a later part of the game okay we did it over sorry about that just
want to see sweat a little bit
oh no dunny is this gate through a maze this may be gate through a maze
uh do you see a maze a zero over
I see I see a gate uh I think it's maze time
uh do you do you have a white gate that you have entered over
I have entered the gate on the wall in blood it says bring down the
guiding light okay I have a map a zero to to get you through this maze are you ready for
instructions over I'm so ready over uh all right uh go north and then go east all the way east
I'm going to check if that blue gate is open or not I'm sorry did you say north copy I'm over
yes from the white gate as you enter go north into a wall and then east into a wall
okay so this way
I think means on a timer if I'm not okay I'm at a I'm at a wall where there's a dog in Campbell
yes um go north and then east then north is that blue gate open or locked
oh fuck she's at the blue gate blue gate blue gate blue gate blue gate she's at the blue
oh I can't go east there's nothing there oh sorry west west sorry it was north and then west over
she should be here are you at a blue gate over it is open the blue gate is open okay
fuck um I need you to go north past the blue gate
and and then take east but take the first west as you go east so she's gonna be here
after that instruction
oh shit she's blue oh I'm sorry I'm sorry Azura please go back where you've came
wait wait wait wait hold on I'm being dumb
shit where is she where are you darling
yeah uh can you give me a a gate color or something
I've balled this up I think I balled this up what gate what did I do so if she goes here
she could close that green which closes that off and then she's locked in here so it can't be that
she has to go back and open up this blue and then what go up here and then close that and then she
can walk do that and then she can go in here do that which will lock that but then she can go
all the way back and then close and then in and then open and in okay uh where are you Azura on
any gate color the blue one okay can you go back to the white gate over hold on no it's blue
um yes can you make your way to the white gate where you entered
oh do you need I can tell you where to go
if you're at the blue gate go south
okay I'm back at the beginning okay right let's try that again
please go northeast and then enter the room to the right
this is a good puzzle I like this one honestly
there's a hallway here and yes in the room there we have blue lever
there's also a jump scare in this blue corridor here that she has no idea about
I wonder if she's gonna spot it or if she's gonna be too late
have you pulled a blue lever over
please repeat that over I have hit the lever okay uh walk up the stairs again and then this time
go west I'm just gonna go here and that was my throat if you heard that there you go a little
burp for your reefing okay I went west okay now you should be able to go north
she should see the jump scare up here if I'm not mistaken but maybe she was too late
wait what's on the floor wait wait wait there's something there with you
is it gonna get you
okay I think we need to hurry before it gets you okay go up that corridor
is that a horror game no it's not a horror game oh what are you talking about no
did you go up the corridor where the monster was over
I'm here I'm here I'm here okay if you take east and then north there's a blue gate past the blue gate
in that room there's a green lever pull the green lever
I don't see a blue gate oh you didn't come
oh here oh no
did you see the blue gate over why is mommy the blue gate okay in that room past the blue gate
is a green lever pull it
should I should I scare and say the monster's gonna get her I pulled it okay now go back
the way you came through the blue gate
all the way back to the white gate
I'm going all the way back yeah just make sure to look behind you in case it's there
it can't get her it can't get her
are you at the white gate I'm in the beginning now okay now I want you to go east
and into the room the first room east and there's a blue lever pull it
my wish she is evil so east and then the first room east yes they're blue
blue lever pull the blue lever yes over I keep interrupting the game doesn't allow two way comms
hello have you pulled the blue lever over I have I already pulled it yeah okay give me one second
sorry I need to do something in order to see it long okay now that you've pulled the blue lever
go back up the stairs and go east and then north
I'm just watching her model to see what she does
okay I'm not okay then you should take a west and a north and you'll see a blue gate that's open
it's closed where the fuck is it closed did you pull did you pull the blue lever twice
no was I supposed to no no it's fine go back into that room and pull that blue lever it's the
first room if you go backwards I don't know how she managed that did I say the wrong comm
I might have said the wrong comm honestly almost let her drown too that room looks like the
freaking maze I thought we were doing the maze in that okay I pulled it back up okay now go north
east north west west do you want me to go west no no no so up the stairs north and then east
north east blue gate is up okay go through that blue gate and to your right you'll see a green gate
that's open come on you can do it baby come on I think there's one more jump scare somewhere here
maybe misremember another green gate I want to do the green green great green great great great
there's a red lever please pull it I pulled the red lever thank you now go back to the blue gate
you just came through over she's fine she's gonna do it she's got it she's got it are you teasing
you just teasing I'm just teasing we're all just teasing periser I don't think she pulled it again
after seeing it she got too scared are you at the blue gate over are you at it yeah I keep talking
over are you at the blue gate over
fuck this is annoying thing are you at the blue gate over
yes I'm at the blue gate over okay keep going backwards and flick the blue lever it'll be the
first room that you come across going backwards over we'll have to tease and bully mummy in the
future stream to avenge Azura well Azura admitted to me she was trolling me in the among us collab
because she said she liked my Scottish accent coming out and she said when I'm angry it comes out
really quickly and I'm like oh I see how it is Azura okay I'll wait for her to pull that lever
I'll wait for her to communicate to me that she should be here is that the blue lever flicked over
okay go north and then take a west
this is about to time out I'm gonna very quickly do that and she just needs to go north
and we do love the angry scores Azura is one of us try to get my Scottish readout
take him west and then go north
and she's doing fine is the monster there still I don't know I don't know where it is
I don't know okay you're almost there you're doing great take an east and then you should
go past the blue gate over me just casually reminding her there's a slug somewhere in the
building although there is a map that she can get got on oh no it might be me that can get got
possibly okay I'm in here you've passed the blue gate there's a green lever pull it
she's looking for I can see her little eyes on her model looking left and right
she's found okay now go through the green gate over over go through the green gate and then take
the first west exit over where is this green gate it should be right next to the green lever if
you go north and east of the green lever over you mean the theater at the end right yeah I think
I can get got if only I could have teased her you got it are you out yeah I passed the gate
aw yeah okay I think this opens up for me because that's the only place that's locked for me
yeah where do I go from here there's a red gate open do I go through the red gate yeah if it's open
you should go through it that's what we we did all that for all those shenanigans hey checkpoint
reach let's go is there a yes I got my achievement yeah I'm cold I'm freezing oh shit I forgot
about this one how do I do this oh there's a chess board there yes there most certainly is
I will give you your instructions momentarily tihi uh do you know how chess boards work do you
know pawn pieces and chess did that go how the fuck does start this what the fuck it go
how do I start this
how do I what did that even go on no I did what
how do I start up I just turned on the machine I don't know what I just did but I turned on a
okay is it fully turned on I think oh god yeah it's fully turned on oh shit why is this not working
I know this is what this is supposed to do
oh uh okay get ready for communication I'm ready okay wait pawn piece in front of the queen forward
two oh shit I need a pen I need a fucking pen are you serious how am I supposed to remember this
okay wait pawn queen before queen two holy shit I'm supposed to remember that wait I forgot the
person's one which one the black or the white wait pawn before queen two steps forward
did I need to wind this up every time
that was the king wait hi
wait it was the king I apologize
the cat do you know where the king position is
yeah I'm looking at him okay the pawn before the king two steps forward
you have which one the black one or the white one wait
no matter if you're black or white hello the black one wait pawn
I think she's talking over me wait pawn by accident I don't think she means that black
pawn before king two two forward and then it goes way
way fucking I moved the one that was in front of the king two steps forward one two three I am dying
I know you're that I am aware you're dying okay did you move the white pawn before the king
two forward yes I did no use no move the black pawn before the king two forward
once I make my move you're free to check I moved it forward no no move sorry no move
white bishop three diagonal to the left one two three diagonal
I'm sorry but what oh mother mother fucker hold on mother fucker hold on pause but I'm fucking
trying wait black black what black fucking horse it was a bishop I'm gonna die it's a diagonal one
the diagonal one black horse pawn what what's diagonal
now hold on a minute now hold on a minute how do I move the the bishop wait okay I move the
bishop where white bishop three diagonal it would be to your left side please tell me you
know the difference between left and right my darling okay
three steps diagonally left one two three over oh three steps diagonally left one two three over
please tell me she knows what diagonal is okay next if you're looking from the white side of the
board the black horse to the left pawn the the pawn in front of the black horse on the left
move him forward one
okay okay and then the queen diagonal I can't see you I know I know white queen
pawn from the black horse move him where
black horse pawn move him forward one on the left from the white side does that make sense
please make sense she I'm fucking confusing the fuck out of her I'm gonna have to tell her she
needs to do it from a white white side oh my god that sounds so bad okay right hold on white queen
diagonal two right oh shit you have to do this from the white side of the board does that make
sense you need to be on the white side of the board this is sounds racist as fuck are you dead
shit I think we need a restart on ironic loop I have something
if you want to give it a shot again white pot now do this from the white side of the
board white pawn before king two forward I did it black pawn before king two forward
what was the horse one pawn before black horse on the left side move forward one
oh she done it I don't know I have it I have the steps I have the steps I've wrote them down
queen's gambit never been so hard for real for real literally when she said what's diagonal
oh I've got it I've got the steps now though I've got the steps now you ready retry from checkpoint
you ready yeah okay click retry from checkpoint oh we so had that I literally just got the last
fucking thing oh we so had that right hold on are you in the snow again over I'm about to be okay
put the generator on first over I already know what the steps are though I think we've got it I'm
just gonna watch I was getting I was getting a bit confuzzled I can't believe oh my god I wasn't
just MLG pro the first time I played a game oh shocking shocking come on come on give it to
me give it to me come on wind that motherfucker or Danny wait until the machine has been turned on
over okay now you're ready for instructions over I'm ready for instructions you must play from
the white side of the board first step white pawn before the king two forward
uh it's forward black pawn before king two forward
got it copy white bishop three diagonal left move it left side one two three
got it okay black horse pawn on left side from the white perspective move him forward one move
the porn the pawn in front of the horse one the board no no no you never heard that
fucking stern as there's tight bow jangles excuse me I did it next move the white queen diagonal
to the right two times one two over stop Freudian slips stop look I'm a bit pent up it's been
a while it's been a while okay got it move the black horse that's on the left side from the
white perspective in an L formation to the right please don't reset I'll cry I will cry
reset got it last now white queen goes forward until she hits one pawn hit the pawn the first
black pawn all the way up the board yes that's my zura this is still lost motherfucker let me
out of here I'm like stuck in this library I have a book here with symbols on it oh I have
books scattered around with symbols are you ready uh random um one um I have to explain these
symbols I have books scattered around with five symbols although they mean any there's one with
ears on it look like one with ears is icy which are pointy ears there and there's one with a
little flag at the tip of a mountain and then a guy in a jacuzzi over yeah a guy in a jacuzzi
and then there's a lantern with three circles three lights diamonds or circles over the heck is that
she said some guy standing on a boat wait with one eyeball I mean that's exactly what she's just
um as the fourth symbol got diamonds on the head and hands
no it's just a lantern like it's definitely circles over and then like three three two sticking out of
it on each side looks like the lamp like a lamp like Lumiere from Beauty and the Beast oh okay okay
whoa whoa whoa um is icys head fucking massive for her body
oh is icys head massive over
icys head is
decent these these medium is the hill humongous over oh big head with two arms sticking out
yeah two tiny stick arms for the first symbol body half oval body half oval body I don't think this
was the right one actually for the second symbol um is the hill like really massive over yeah it looks
like a boom a boob no is it skinny I don't know what these books I can't remember what the freaking
book stage was well these books are so similar to what she's explaining it could be this one
um no it can't be that one because she said the last one's like a boat no it can't be that one either
um can you input these symbols anywhere like uh
I don't know what she needs me to do uh
uh
is it maybe down here that's the secret adrenaline is pumped okay so I walked onto a platform and
it murdered me oh um
okay I'm just I'm just trying to investigate what I can do for you
murdered her I don't have any instructions when I look at these books though there's like
it's just floor spears oh it only lets me give you the symbols I think I
the floor where there are no spear I know what to do okay you need to explain the symbols in
high detail okay did the symbols restart
I'm to look at the back of the book no it's yes the symbols did in fact restart but they
still look similar it's similar they are very similar on my end first one looks the same it's
like a small like oval half oval body with two sticks sticking out like a snow oh you know like
the snowman we the snowman one with the funny face what this one is now a face with the ears
are we different is it a fat necko vtuber yes or no yes that's okay with pointy ears is the next
one a medium pentus that has a little thing in his urethra over at this time with a line going
through the mountain like it's like a scoop that is a pentus and just one singular tip pointing
out that is a pentus pointing out that is a pentus as two big balls is it like a bird's eye view of
the balls there's a guy in a tucuzi still their head is a oval like a flower is it squished over
the the lantern has changed it now has three legs uh-huh yes that's not third leg is there three
diamonds on the tips at the top okay i think i've got the right one for once with with with pointy
with pointy pointy stick at the top yes yes not descending oh even when the sand is at the back
and then a person standing on a boat they have a dress one eyeball with oval head
actually really good was slightly bigger okay for the third symbol is oh she's a little hair on
their head there's no hair on the head just a stick yeah there's one one one little stick one
hair on the head one stick for the third symbol is the head of the man in the jacuzzi quite flat
but still an oval over yeah flat flat and oval right i have the correct thing but you need to
let me read all of it before you start moving okay okay okay now i'm going to read the instructions
out loud do not do them until i've read the full thing and we've figured it out okay because this
will keep resetting if we muck up in the western corner lies your start keep moving north but watch
your step before the last tile you must head east after those these two steps take one step towards
the south head for the eastern wall then you may proceed towards the door over so that
so just so you comprehend we have to follow these steps in order over okay oh yeah okay yeah yeah
yeah she has no fucking clue that's okay i love her okay and the western hemisphere is where you start
so the first but don't stand on it okay just where you start okay she did she's talking but she's not
talking at the very end yeah like to the left the west is where you start but don't stand on it okay
okay is she okay i'm ready to stream snap okay i'm here
but before the last tile you must head east wait how far east after these two okay i'm ready
okay you are going to start going forwards but before the very last tile you must stop
do not go on the last tile go on the second last tile north if that makes sense okay
surely happy she's a happy happy are you on it yeah kind of over
i'm there okay you must now go all the way east okay over
copy i've seen copy not happy
you must head east oh i meant east just by one tile oops
i'm sorry ray let's try again let's try again are the symbols the same or different
heaps head east one of course they didn't say head east multiple oh luckily they're the same
oh is it the exact same i mean she ain't gonna complain if it's the exact same
lucky okay let's try that again but this time i will not fill it up tea
are you ready
i'm ready on the most western corner is where you start
i'm here go north but stop on the like second last one
before the last gun now go east once
gun take one step towards the south head for the eastern wall then you may proceed to the door
take one step towards the south over
i lied after these two steps one take one step towards the south did you go south or north
you said south that's what the book says
what do you say the book says after these two steps oh two steps as in physically two steps bro
oh she went south oh my god i think it means two steps east brah i got played by english
brah okay let's try that again brah i literally got played by english i hate the english language
so much so what's the symbol is it the same it's not good it's the same you're very lucky
no way is it actually yeah they're the same i love it here okay western wall let's go
i've killed her so many times now right nothing can chase her you said two steps east right no
right i'm going to read it out to you and then we can use our logic together okay
she's talking but she's not okay right it says in the western corner lies your start so we'll go
there i'm there keep moving north but watch your step before the last tail okay so don't go all the
way north okay she's nodding she's nodding again okay now don't go anywhere read this with me okay
before your last tail you must head east okay so you can go east one you don't die on east one
okay then the book says after these two steps so you can go east twice question mark
so go east one to what she's doing she's i don't know if i should go to that tile i think i died on
the tile twice okay twice i just went one more step okay so you've gone east twice technically yes
if i step on this child wait wait wait i died on this don't go don't go don't go don't go don't go
don't go don't go oh don't go so from so from the western side you've gone east twice technically
yes yes okay now it says take one step towards the south head to the eastern wall then you may
proceed towards the door so i think you go south once then all the way east and then all the way
that makes sense right over
oh thank god i'm not doing that one again that was shite that's shite being Scottish that was awful
fucking english why did they do english like that brave right i'm going in a okay this is the one
where i can die i can see her model she has no idea what's going on she can hear it though
there's a show and i'm being hunted and she has no idea i'm just gonna let her have fun
she'll figure out she'll figure out it's fine he has to watch them so i am on the other side of the show
a movie you are going to be pulling out scenes for me to watch
uh uh uh
um there should be a narration lever if i'm not mistaken
there's gonna be a monster right behind me isn't there oh it's not there yet well he comes up soon
there's a couple of lovers
two levers forbidden for being fooled in a horror puzzle game there's a goat goddess and a kulfish
and we have room temperature iq and i forget how the rest of the song goes but
super hard puzzles super hard puzzles they're really difficult because they're super super super
hard puzzles as they will get revenge there's the enemies sneaking up on me do you have a narration
lever what's what's that what's in a what a lever it's a lever that literally has narration on it
or maybe scene one something like that yeah it's a scene one on it if you pull it i think it gives
you dialogue scene one or does it give me the dialogue and i'm to tell her what to do with that
man i wish i could sit in the seats um
to the left and the right there should be like three levers for her to pull
how about you just pull everything out
would you want to pull out a zero i didn't say that to her i was asking the reflings to be honest
would you pull out of a zero i don't think you would you shouldn't all the girls are designed
not to be pulled out of uh do you see levers that you can mess with
yes i do one lever is broken though okay uh pull out of the other levers and i think i will be able
to see what you're doing
whoa Poseidon you didn't have to do that you goofy goober thank you for the redirect Poseidon
did you have fun i'm pretty sure you're putting replay book one tcg if i'm not mistaken do you
see that uh you'll need to pull it out more please i don't see anything
hi raiders thank you Poseidon for the redirect i'm pretty sure Poseidon tweet she's like i'm
playing more tcg like an absolute chad um i don't see anything happening on my end
oh hold on a minute i'm a brain lit hold on pause jump okay what's this okay i'm an idiot
oh there it is
there once was a castle filled with life
well i'm glad dessert didn't see this she would freak out bye okay what does that mean why is
your creepy music playing uh because i'm being hunted right now but don't worry that's for me
to worry about you just do a castle filled with life okay wait how am i supposed to do that what
what do you mean you're being hunted it's fine it's fine i'm willing to die for you just pull a lever
and make a castle full of life that's what that's what you've been given but hi uh Poseidon readers
i'm strony calls from vlr the thought agency um Poseidon's awesome by the way if you didn't know
she's like super cool and chill um just let you guys should know not that you already knew not that
you didn't know you already knew that fill the castle with life literally she has no idea i'm
getting hunted right now i think she would freak out seeing this if i'm being honest it's probably
better in the end i did this side because i think is there would have a heart attack if she saw that
no guess we go low and i is a little puppeteer type thing i saw Poseidon's yeah Poseidon got a
2.0 model recently i don't know if Azura knows what she better stop jingling a lingon
wait why oh that like kills my pov
can i like die if i get too close oh i won't let me actually get closer to him that's quite
interesting it blocks me from getting closer it's definitely a marionette i do like creepy creepy
marionette vtuber confirmed why am i supposed to do i don't know what to do um so you are sending out
a play um and the cardboard cutouts are like a king a queen a castle the people and your prompt is
there was a castle full of life there is a castle but there's only there's only
i'm so dead
i'm so dead but yes Poseidon got a 2.0 model if you didn't see it it was a
that's very big not blood light not yet that's later
can she not find all the six levers there's six levers there might be levers on the opposite
side of the room i am so dead it's fine
oh that was wrong well i didn't like that wherever that was
it's okay it's okay i suck at video games i die in them all the time it's fine um
um right there once was a castle full of life
he got closer
thank god i played this game before because i'm not gonna lie this is really creepy the first
time you play there at the hotel or just pill stuff um just pill stuff all the way out if you can
like a castle a king a queen and a crowed i'm just straight up telling her what i remember
from the gameplay i think that's what she has to do right now
these they're like in separate rooms oh
she's just discovered the other ones she's just discovered the other one she's so cute i love her
i will embrace sweet death the eternal slumber in the name of the yetpricorn
the blood light is oh i can see what you're pulling out i think keep pulling the handles
am i being an idiot is that supposed to be watching this entire time i'm me just leaving
her to do the guesswork what are you doing is this is this the castle um no you've pulled out
in a marriage arch way it looks like
i don't see anything else with a castle and except for those have you pulled the things all the way
out i actually see like half of a king it's ogre it's so ogre they'll have to admit this is probably
the heart oh you're pulling out people i see people
i see people but they're not pulled out all the way oh they're going away again
oh they're coming out again hey hi people okay it was my fault i'm supposed to guide her and
what to do okay that's yeah yeah that's them all the way out so i've got people in a castle
oh i can't even i just walk okay i may or may not have been hunted by a monster and i didn't
want to stress you out i didn't want to stress you out but i was being hunted i was being hunted
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry right are you ready to try that game we know what to do this time
okay okay this is like the last scene anyway and then we're done i think uh right
wait my door's locked
motherfucker wait oh no do we have to do that pathway one again
oh of the door is your door locked as well the spikes yeah oh come on
the symbols are different this time
um right hit me with the symbols we have to go back okay i'm gonna read
ready okay the one is a big head a big icy head laying on a floor
no laying on the floor the second one is the same a big big peepee with balls
i don't know if that's everyone is a wally pop with with um that one
a wally pop inside of a a hill
what the fourth one is oh yeah i think i think i'll go to it's like another lantern but
have you seen a lantern right curved oh my game just curved with three legs i have absolutely
terrible i think my game is fucking good are you serious okay that was a really good three balls
on top okay i think i got the book symbol is a box a tiki mask with tiny hands on its head
yeah i got a red one and three other boxes two small box eyes and a big box mouth
how the fuck did i rotate this right way so i can read it easily wait how the fuck okay i got it
okay this has tricky language in it again for the english speakers are you ready
is that a yeah i never heard that i saw our model move but i don't know if that's the end
okay i'm going to read the whole thing out but don't do anything
first okay just let me read it all out okay she's going up and down i see her
fucking boobs dry rain stop stop stop sexualizing your fucking enemies right before one starts in
the east take one step westward then starting by taking two steps north take one more step north
but not before moving one step west so we need to do a move in between a move go west some more till
one hits the wall then head straight for the door what why is she using her fucking confusion thing
i'm using it too okay are you ready
are you ready over yeah i'm so ready yeah yeah both of us are fucking like this right now okay
go eastward but do not stand on anything
why is it how is she sticking her tongue out
okay if you are eastward
go one tail to the left like to the west but don't stand on it yet okay
is she done that all these are cute tongue hanging out right now
okay i'm there okay let me read one second let me read ahead then start by taking two steps north
take one more step north but not before going west okay go two steps north
she's done it
done take one step west
shall i begin silly i didn't know she could toggle her tongue out paramount
done take one more step north
is she doing it
done go west more till one till one hits the wall then head straight to the door go all the way west
okay
then go all then head straight for the door
okay we did that one that actually went super well
the achievement is called vlad then paler if we play that perfectly okay let's do this again
i twatted this up i just assumed this was locked that was on me
okay you can now bring out the castle
is the story the same yes there once was a castle filled with life
we're getting silly get silly that's why we gotta finish this i'm gonna fart on this game
how dare they make it so difficult they made the letter we were here so difficult for no reason
like it's terrible okay an archway is coming out pull it all the way out is that it all the way
is it is that all the way i can't see can you rotate it anymore like rotate the handle anymore
okay yeah that came out further
but good yeah okay next please
did you know vlad then paler didn't start paling until people in his 30s
why was he so obsessed with shoving sticks up his butt no up other people's butt hold on sorry
sorry not his butt in particular i'm rewriting history right now who's fiend okay no well you
can do that again you can rotate it the other way again
now pick another crank
oh what did she say oh okay now the towns people are coming out keep going keep going keep that
crank going bring it on yeah yeah yeah yeah okay next crank
hit him with the next crank
she got butt stuff on her main look yeah yeah doing that and more cranks
is that it is that the full of life are they inside the castle i think we might need i don't
know pull the stage there should be a scene lever you can pull it and i'll tell you if it's right or
wrong okay that's wrong so we need something more you got more levers somewhere maybe the opposite side
i have more levers you don't have any more any crank a light
she's got butts done it's Johnny's way too random something can't keep up huh
that takes the impaler title to a whole new level literally man was a fiend
she was just projecting how dare you look at it's been a while okay it's been a while
okay you put the blood light on we don't need blood light
now there should be other cranks that you can turn look for another room
oh no there's nothing else i can turn there's just two rooms with the thingies in it be the
surely they go on the stage and yeah there's no other cranks to pull over
now there's no other cranks to pull okay if there's no other cranks pull the current ones you can pull
they need to be in the arch way well in the light okay
oh but you pulled out princess this is new
you
pull her more yeah okay you've brought out oh no put him away put him away put him away no
he's about yeah yeah yeah go go go go go okay um can you pick a castle or the people
yeah that's okay pull it out more i think you need to crank it six times until it's in where it
should be yeah yeah yeah uh can you pull the castle more
okay okay perfect right the townspeople can you move them more
pull the lever
um can you put the princess and the king away question mark
she is try hard and i can see her little face is focused and i can see it in her eyes look at her go
was it this one perfect yeah that was a princess next to king please
okay is it isn't this one yeah yeah yeah keep going
god this one's a really difficult one repeat that yeah yeah move that king keep doing that one
that you're doing yeah perfect okay now pull the scene please
oh okay thank you please
there lived a king and his wife in a castle
king and his wife
god my my please pull out the king and the queen at your next convenience with the castle as well
please god this was really hard for no reason right hold on stage one is just towns people
and castle i assume
okay at least we're making progress okay pull out king and queen more please and castle scene
man he's really excited for the show god damn okay more on the castle more on the castle please
one more one more if you can and then for the king and queen can you push them out a bit more
she is focusing so her is she talking like or is that toggle she put me she made a toggle
no no other way other way for the princess sorry other way for the princess
is that okay and then pull scene please i assume this is what is king queen
okay okay that's fine
um the prompt was all we're happy and all was good so bring everyone out except the evil king
i don't know right that was castle king and queen for that one sorry it's so easy to play puzzle
games if you can just write down shit right stage um all we're happy and all was good so
i actually just got shivers there i don't like that so queen king god he's like doing the splits
and everything all we're happy and all was good um bring out the king and the princess and the
townspeople more please we ain't making this one alive we ain't making it alive she got that tongue
she's being playful with us she's like um maybe maybe townspeople once more and then pull the lever
let's you POV a wreathling at a convention
oh actually now what what's next uh can you pull the lever did it not like it
oh it didn't like that maybe bring out the castle
all right more more more more give me give me give me give me give me yeah give me yeah give me
one more one more one more and then pull the scene
oh uh maybe oh piss
bruh this one's so hard okay the good news is we've made progress we've made progress
so we know what stage one and two is we just need to find out what stage three and assume there's a
four bruh this one's hard i thought this was gonna be easy but you you know what to do right
we both know what to do you ready to go again yeah but there's a there is a there is a like a
like one with a shell on it a shell there you brought a king with a sword at one point which
is for a later part um yeah there was there was one with a shell on it um but i didn't bring that one
out oh we'll we'll find out what it does in a minute we'll find out what it does in a minute
okay okay no no this one's hard this one everything else came up before that's pretty
simplistic and then this one gets like really hard for no reason
okay you ready yeah i'm ready retry from checkpoint yeah oh no we have to do the freaking thing again
oh right reflincher legit just gonna have to tell me because i actually have to go somewhere today
that's why i asked us to play it ever early symbol time symbol time you guys are gonna you
to make a good day unfortunately yes i'll do i i'll i'd drag my dick through a mile of glass to
hear you fart through a walkie-talkie with her different hand okay hit me with him she didn't
hear that by the way before you guys really it's the big head but it's on a stick with two arms
a big head and it's on a stick with two arms you guys looking for the big head now a guy with a
tiny body two arms looks like a bicycle rod and really long legs with two feet wait what's the first
neko symbol the big head the big head with two arms okay and then is the second symbol a really long
hill yeah they got they got long legs and then jacuzzi man
i'm trying to speed run through this is the man on a boat got a squarish head
no there's no one on the boat there's no boat shit it's the box again it's the box with the
two small arms on its head and she said big neck square eyeballs and two in a big square mouth
sure me sure me sure me sure me sure me sure me sure me what can't be that one because it's
got a bow on it right i can't find it right it's not in here why would it be in here the third one
is a jacuzzi uh it's in the jacuzzi one again they got really curled legs they curled up legs and
a big cross in its head okay across that can't be that one that it must be something up here
hello is there a book up here hello wait there's a book all down there
right it's got a cross cross cross cross the the the lantern is all straight lines like squares
and it's and it has uh got by me three circles
three circles on the lollipop guy what the fuck am i having a stroke i might be having a stroke
i can't seem to find this fucking book there's no way the book's down here why would it be down
here i have no idea
am i going crazy did i look at it did i look at the book
you should see i then love the walkie talkie
am i going crazy what are you confused on when i can't seem to
find what you're describing the last one's a tiki mask yes on the symbol
ah tiki mask yeah yeah okay i'm just gonna have to do it that way so no boat tiki mask only
and then we'll investigate tiki mask let's see so it can't be that one you so it has to be um
is the oh she's talking is the fourth symbol a guy with circular head and hands and his
legs are flat like a standee yes okay i think and the first one is ac celebrating with her hands up
yeah she has no legs sad rip okay we got her chicken nugget ac unlocked right i've got it i've
got it i've got it okay as always i'm gonna read the full thing first to digest what the
hidden agenda is okay starting in the far west take two steps northbound head east twice
then after moving north two times one can head for the door after taking one step towards the
western wall okay now let's digest this starting in the far west so go to the west side but don't
stand on it i will cry if she stands on it a little blind but i could not find that one okay
take two steps north
please don't die please don't die please don't die
please don't die i'm dead head east twice please don't die please don't die please don't die
then after moving north two times you have we got it
you what you did it you did it yeah yeah yeah yeah okay okay okay
then after moving north two times one can head through the door after taking
one step towards the eastern wall. Go north two times. Is this gonna kill her? I'm getting
nervous. You got it? What's next? Fucking hell, you trying to make me calm? What the fuck?
That's right, but to come to a fucking walkie-talkie, what the fuck is this?
Right, one can head for the door after taking one step towards the dead west once.
There's gonna be more than vibrations coming through this damn walkie-talkie, the fuck?
Now you can head to the door after the western step you did.
Oh my god. Oh yeah, that's our job. Soon give me literally less than a week.
Okay, we can speedrun this. We know what to do. Are you ready?
Okay. Yes, I'm ready. Okay. First up, towns, people, and castle only. Push,
put, yep, all the way, all the way, all the way, all the way, all the way. One more,
one more for the castle. The perfect towns, people, next. Let's speedrun this bitch.
Push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push,
scene, scene, scene, scene.
Beautiful, gorgeous, a garden, 10 out of 10.
I just did that on the mic. Castle King, Queen all the way out, push, push, push,
she just coughed in her mouth there, like a fucking toddler. Push castle more, castle more,
more, more, more, until, almost, all the way, all the way, all the way, all the way, all that way.
One more castle, one more castle, one more king, one more king, one more queen, otmer queen, one more
King, King, King, King, King, King, King, King, King.
Okay, scene.
This must be so confusing on her end.
Beautiful.
All were happy and all was good.
King, Queen, Castle, Townspeople.
Push, push, push, push.
I have absolutely no idea if that's the correct one.
Push, push, push, push the castle.
Push that castle.
Teacher, yeah, yeah, teacher who's boss.
That's right, King next.
Fuck up that King.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's right, yeah.
Get that Queen in.
Get them Townsfolk in.
Yeah.
Is she laughing?
I think she's laughing.
Okay, Townspeople, Townspeople.
Bring them in, bring them in.
Hey, hey, hey, celebrate with the King and Queen.
More, more, more, more.
Show those peasants what they're missing out on.
Pill that scene.
Oh my God, we did it.
We did it.
King, Queen, that was Castle and Townspeople.
Okay, now let's find out what's happening in this next scene.
What's next?
Until the King killed all he could,
give me Evil King.
Put the good King away.
Boo, put the King away.
Boo.
We need Evil King now.
I don't know which one the King is.
Yep, perfect, perfect, all the way.
Get rid of that.
Boo.
Right, now we need Evil King out.
Evil King, Evil King.
Oh, here he comes.
Push, push, push him all the way out.
Perfect, perfect.
Oh, he's deranged, he's deranged.
Okay, now we need the bloodlights in the back.
You piss off, I'm working hard.
Okay, scene.
Until the King killed all he could.
Oh, he's crazy.
He's absolutely mental.
He's deranged.
Standing in blood, he probably said.
Standing in blood, he proudly said,
give me Blood King in Castle.
Maybe Blood King in Light,
and that's the Evil King in the Bloodlight.
I think that might be it.
Everyone away, Bloodlight on.
Okay, perfect, and Bloodlight on and scene.
No, no, that's the Bloodlight off, sorry.
Pop that bad boy back on.
And then pull scene.
Shit, you might need to bring out
the dead townspeople, I don't even know if that's possible.
He just says.
I don't think there's dead.
Oh, oh, oh, sorry, bring out the normal King again.
He just says standing in blood.
Maybe one, maybe, can you bring out
the Evil King any further?
Sorry, see if you can wind him out any further.
No, no, okay, maybe put Evil King away
and bring out normal King,
because he's just standing in blood, so with a Bloodlight.
What's the stage four?
Oh, I'm dying, ho ho ho, hurry up, Azura.
Hee hee, love you, love you, Mummy, please, sorry,
please don't let me die.
Okay, perfect, and then put away Evil King.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, go away, Evil King.
You stink, boo, boo, thumbs down.
Okay, pull scene.
You did it!
You did it, go down into the attic thing.
What the fuck was that noise, God damn.
Oh my God, that was a painful one I've dead met.
Hey, see me, hi.
You still have to talk to me through the walkie-talkie, though.
Oh my God, oh, your walkie-talkie's just hovering.
No, Azura, you might be the mother of all creations, okay?
Of all life on this earth, so it's you who must go on.
Go ahead, I will stand on the pressure plate
and you will get freedom that you deserve.
Your creations need you.
Go forth, Azura, into the snow.
What happened in you?
It is the sacrifice I must make, for I am a siren.
I take life, but you are the goddess of fertility you give.
Go on forth to humanity.
Give them the love they deserve.
She went.
No!
You did it.
Was there another way, question mark?
That was amazing, you did it, Azura.
Hee-hee-hee.
You did it!
You did it, that was fantastic, you did so well.
You were worried about nothing.
I don't think so.
It was good, you did fantastic.
Hee-hee-hee.
Wait, what did you think?
What did you think of that game type?
Yes or no?
I was, that was hard.
I'm not good at puzzles at all.
That, the last one was painful.
I have to admit, that was really hard to figure out.
Even, I've played the game before
and I kind of knew what you were doing on your end
and I still couldn't figure it out from the other perspective.
So don't feel dumb, that was hard.
It was hard as shit.
I think I should study chessboards more.
Well, I literally was calling the king, the queen at one point
and then Refleens were like, that's the king you moron.
I'm like, oh, okay, okay, I'll deal with it.
So don't worry about it, don't worry about it.
But there's like a whole series on the WiiWare here.
I think there's now four installments of the franchise.
And for some reason, on the very last installment of this game,
they made it so unbelievably hard and difficult for no reason.
And all the other ones?
Yeah, so I've been lucky enough to play them
with other VTubers and another life team.
And the fourth installment is impossible without cheating.
I refuse to believe anyone naturally came up
with one of the answers in them.
But if you ever wanted to give another one a shot,
I'm right here, Azura.
But I don't know if puzzles are your thing.
Well, I don't know if they're your thing.
They're not my thing, I'm dumb.
Oh, that's adorable though, I loved it.
I'm sorry about scaring you about the monster in the maze.
I'm going to be honest, the monster can't get you in the maze.
I was just waning you up, I'm sorry.
That's what you get for waning me up in among us.
We were talking before the stream and she was like,
I purposely picked on you to hear that Scottish accent.
I'm like, Azura, you're not supposed to say that.
She's like, oh, because I was like,
oh, I don't get angry or frustrated.
And she was like, the among us club.
And I'm like, you know what?
You've actually got me there.
I got caught red.
You caught me.
You got me, I'm not going to lie.
It was funny.
Or you got so mad, she'd vote me off immediately.
And then I wasn't even the imposter and then she'd get.
I always, if someone, if anyone picks on me,
I'm like, instantly you're the imposter
because you're worried I'm going to snuff you out.
And then obviously I think I booted you off once
and you were innocent.
And then everyone was like, you're gilly strong.
And I'm like, no, no, Azura is starting then.
You started.
I'm going to end it.
I was so scared.
That was so good.
Thank you so much for playing with me and enjoyed myself
thoroughly.
Are you streaming after this or is that
you done for today?
Because I don't know if I should be direct into year or not.
I'm done for today.
I'm probably just going to chat with my stream for a little bit.
Yes, OK.
I say a little bit, but it's probably
going to be for like two hours.
They didn't call you yet for calling for nothing
around these parts.
OK, let me make sure I'm redirecting into year.
Because I don't want to not direct into year.
But that was so fun.
Please, if you ever wanted to play more of those,
I enjoy those games totally not because I've played them before
and they're not impossible.
Tee, tee.
If I played them fresh, I'd be a lot more nervous
because I'm like, um, but I think we did OK.
I was nervous.
You were going to get upset that I was so dumb.
No, I would never get upset at you for no good.
I mean, like, I was.
Don't get off the puzzle forever.
Oh, bro.
That last puzzle killed us.
Not going to lie.
Everything else.
I don't want this puzzle that I ever.
We blitzed through.
The longest puzzle.
The longest puzzle I've ever gotten stuck on
was like for literally two days straight.
And what?
I'd just cheat at that point.
It was.
I don't think you can cheat, though.
Like, yeah, you can cheat to find out what you have to do.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You have to actually time it.
It was like a timing puzzle.
And I could never get the timing, right?
No, I don't like that kind of stuff.
And apparently there's a game called Labyrinth Co-op Horror Puzzle.
I'm not sure if I can put the girls up for that.
I was freaking Azura pretending a slug was going to grab her.
I don't know how I should respond to a game like that.
I scream.
Terrible.
Right.
I am going to redirect into Azura,
because unfortunately I do have a few things to do today.
And thank you so, so much for playing me.
That was a hoot and a holler.
I'm going to redirect into you.
Reeflings, be lovely to the bleeding hearts.
I'm bleeding hearts.
Thanks for having me as well on your end of things, Azura.
I will redirect into you.
Thank you so, so much.
I give everyone kisses.
And I'm going to dissipate, okay?
I'm going to dissipate.
I'm going to jump out of voice chat first,
because Azura is going to be like, bruh.
She's going to be like, bruh, what's going on here?
Okay.
All right, I take off.
Bye-bye, guys.
Bye.
Bye-bye.